hello everyone and welcome back to the
world rapid championship it's around
three and magnus carlsen faces boris
pochenko Russian Grand Master in a
really exciting game well the title says
it all although it although not too much
so without further ado let's check it
out and for the next game we're gonna
check again by eleven our onion as well
here unbelievable but the dress code is
a well one of the features not features
one of the points in the dress code
let's let's call it that is you are not
allowed to wear bright colors which you
which shouldn't be a problem for most
players but for levin aragon it's
definitely a problem because he is
always the most colorful player in every
tournament so i just wanted to share
that with you guys so without further
ado let's check it out magnus with the
white pieces opens with d4 now we have
d5 Knight to f3 c5 now with III by
magnus and c captures on d4 with ECAP
force on d4 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 now so just going up inning tonight
basically transposing into the caro-kann
defense the exchange variation we have
Bishop to g4 of course if there are any
new players watching if I meant
beginners if 25 checked you don't win a
piece because Knight c3 just defends the
bishop so Bishop to g4 just nicely
continuing development and here a lot of
moves have we played like every move
white can play here has been played here
except the one Magnus plays he plays c4
and well incredible as it is already as
of move six we have a completely new
game
so such chanko continues with Knight to
f6 at the defender to the d5 pawn we
have Knight to c3 and the g6 now
preparing to fianchetto the dark square
Bishop h3 asking black what do you want
to do with the bishop you want to go
back or do you want to trade subchannel
decides the trade captures captures and
now there's a lot of pressure on this d5
pawn so first a six asking now Magnus
what do you want to do with your Bishop
do you want to bring it back to a four
which isn't unreasonable as the black
will not be able to put beef
five so it's definitely a move but
Magnus decides 4c captures on d5 right
away
with Knight captures on d5 Queen
captures on d5 now offering a queen
trade but first a captures on b5 and now
Queen captures on d5 grabbing that pawn
so here Magnus is up a pawn but he will
have a lot of pressure along the a and B
file and he will put subject will put a
bishop on this diagonal so you will have
sort of a pawn compensation like you
would have in a bank Banco gambit where
black definitely has a lot of
compensation for the pawn so here
Bishop to g7 if you're if you're trying
to defend the b7 pawn it's not really
easy if something like this then d5 just
attacks the pin piece and if ruk a5
pushing the Queen back just Queen c4
again you can't move the knight because
now the Queen hands and if Queen e5
checked Bishop to e3 blocks and now you
just have problems you don't really have
any any good squares for the night like
if you move it is just Queen Queen c8
mate it's not the only line but it's the
one I decided to chose to choose as it's
really funny so that's up to g7 offering
the b7 pawn for the d4 pawn so Queen
captures on b7 and now comes Knight
captures on d4 also instead of capturing
and b7 d5 is an option where such a
would probably have to give up his his
dark square Bishop after captures
captures and then go after the point
with Luke the a5 let's say Queen
captures Queen captures and you again
get this position where Magnus is up
upon but black has again a lot of
development white is definitely better
here but you know it's it's a trade off
but okay Magnus prefers
Queen cat for Sun b7 right away with not
Queen captures but Knight captures it
would be weird since the rook would hang
and now comes castles by white so
channel also castles and rook to d1
pinning the knight on d4 we have Queen
to b8 offering a trade and the Queen
back to e4 magnus nicely centralizes the
Queen and now you see that although
Magnus is upper pawn black has immense
pressure along the a and B file and the
bishop slices the board in half nicely
so they're definitely the comp
station for the sacrificed bond we have
f5 pushing the Queen further back Queen
to b3 and now II five so black got rid
of all of his weak points and now he
just says okay I I can hold this now you
do have two connected response on the
Queen side but how are you going to push
them so look the b1 first by Magnus and
here both players have eight minutes on
the clock so it's not another problem
for either of them we have Queen to b4
just putting the Queen to to a very
active square also bit it just prevents
what a wife from pushing any pawns so
Bishop to e3 now continuing development
and rook F to d8 putting the rope to the
the D file where where the Queen
occupies the d3 square and now a three
this is one point you can actually push
but now Queen to b3 and you can you
cannot push any more points however
Magnus decides that now it's time to
give up the dark square bishop and try
and trade queens so we have Bishop
captures rook captures and Queen to b5
as the defender of the be five square
was eliminated we have looked the b8 not
not going for the thread right away but
he wants if the Queens do get traded he
wants to be able to again block the beep
on which looked to be three so Queen the
c5 by Magnus and now Queen to see for
offering the trade here so you can
always go just rook to b3 so Magnus
straight with Queen captures with check
rook captures and now Knight to d5 just
getting the knight to to a nice nice
active square and now rook to b3 if you
if you tried you cannot push her before
right away because the knight is hanging
if you could push before then white
would of course be better but Knight d5
and now rook the b3 again not allowing
Magnus to push any points and here
Magnus really lost a lot of time on the
clock he went down to some 40 at 45
seconds and he played rook to d2
prevents rook to c2 and also just waits
for black to make a move maybe you can
double and under D file well he just has
to wait a black blacks position is much
more active so II for
opening up this finally the dragon
awakens and well the the b2 pond will be
will be under fire
we've g3 by Magnus and the King to f7
Savchenko now starts bringing his King
into the game kingi to Magnus improves
the position of the King as well and now
rook to d4 here Savchenko wants to trade
a pair of rooks and then pick up the b2
pawn
we have rugby to d1 threatening to win
material but now rook captures rook
captures and just Bishop captures an
unbeaten so that's all there is the
cousins extra pawn Savchenko now
eliminates it but he still has the past
a pond so he pushes it pawn to a4 for
the moments of chenko is unable to put a
rope behind the past pawn because the
bishop on b2 would hang so Bushra back
the e5
no not d4 the show back to e5 and now
rook the a to Magnus puts the rook
behind the passed pawn
King e6 brings the King closer to the
center of the board and knights the f4
check here you could trade and go into a
rook and pawn and game but such an Co
decides that he wants the bishop on the
board he wants the block of the pass
pawn with the bishop d4 to a7 so Magnus
contain is pushing the past pawn there
should be four with a six and Bishop to
a 7 ounce of Jenko blocked the past pawn
and Carlson has to figure out what's the
next phase of the game so he pushes h4
we have III now a trading of some points
with F captures an e3 rook captures an
e3 and rook the d2 check King c6 we have
looked the c2 check King d6 and now
Magnus not satisfied with a draw with
the white pieces goes rook all the way
to c8 now with ideas of maybe he can
just undermine the pawn from behind so
looked at east 7 adding a defender to
the 7th rank and king h3 now we have
Bishop to e3
now now black is definitely interested
in trading as the the a6 pawn wouldn't
really go all that far and it's not
difficult to pick it up we have rogue d8
check King to c7 and now rook to d3
now black takes this opportunity to get
rid of the night
Bishop captures G captures and King
Tubby six going after the pawn Magnus
defends it rook to a3 and now well you
can put a rook to a7 and claim a draw
this way and just capture it and you
will be in time to prevent everything on
the King side King to a7 works just as
well and now you have an active rook and
the King blocks the pawn but now Magnus
will be able to activate his rook as
well so first Magnus clears clears the
path for his skin with h5 he can now
enter the position will with king h4 to
g5 we looked at a four goes after the
pawn and now rook to f3 it's a very
interesting move that allows world lock
the capture a six pond but also the
effort ponies are protected and Magnus
will get his King into play so King
captures an a6 King to h4 now so it's
Magnus who's down upon but it's now
Magnus who is pushing for more than a
draw because of the the not so active
black King we have king b6 black tries
to bring his King back to where the
actions at King g5 will work the east
six not allowing the trade here and now
comes rip the c3 Magnus cuts off the
black King from the front now from
entering the game we look back to d6
giving white the move but now h6 so
what's what's the idea behind h6 well
you will soon find out here we have
looked the c6 attacking the rook hoping
turn now at the trade rooks but we have
looked back to III and now rook to c4
and now if King f6 you can capture the
f4 pawn however also possible was rook
to c7 right away just guarding the
seventh rank because now if King to f6
rope the d7 the rook to these efforts
black has to make a move and now rook to
e7 doesn't work because you can just
trade after captures captures you can
start doing me the King into the game
and even though your king is far behind
you are you will be able to make a draw
here because after King f6 you're gonna
go King d5 King g7 King e6 captures and
now king f7 is a draw because the White
King is unable to leave the corner of
the board
I just this will be enough for for a
draw because if you put upon
it's actually white who's winning white
who's winning
so after rook to e3 like I said rook to
c7 would have been a good attempt but
rook the c4 was played and now Magnus
just goes rook to e7 goes after the pawn
here looked the c7 now but now feel free
to pause the video and try to figure out
the best move for white to continue this
game it's it will be a nice end game
practice for you well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on being an excellent endgame player and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's rook to g7 now the king
has time to enter the game then you will
trade and then New York King is already
here to start picking up ons so King to
c6 was played King f6 we have rook to
the seven now King the e6 threatening to
win material here so look back to d4 but
now rook captures on h7 we have rook
captures on f4 and now rook to h8 we
have looked to h4 now finally a
Savchenko puts a look behind the past
pawn but h7 now the thread is just a
rook c8 check and you'l queen the pond
so king's to b7 not well now you can
check but it doesn't really work so kink
the f6 going after the pawns here we
have f4 but now King captures on g6 rook
the g4 check here King to h5 and we have
looked a g1 Magnus e'er played rook to
f8 just referring to Queen the pawn and
it was in this position on mu 62 that
Russian Grandmaster board Savchenko
resigned the game as the endgame is now
completely lost once you give a few
checks let's say check in g6 would you
want checking a5 you can no longer play
this because after Luke h1 white Queens
the pawn or you can bring the rook into
again doesn't really matter
characters captures and after you start
pushing the pawn white just stops it
like f2 you put a room behind the passed
pawn win it and then checkmate the black
ink so after this rook c7
who know after this rook to f8 move as
of chanko resigned the game and a
victory for Magnus Carlsen in round 3
which puts him on 2 & a half
out of three definitely better than what
he had last year so now once again
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Doug McNabb Edward
Baker Maxime Poisson and she and 1998
and Torrance Fike for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serum thank all for
watching and I will see soon continuing
the coverage of the world rapid
championship I've seen some of you
already suggest Levin's game and the
game Alireza vs. core above seemed
really interesting so we're going to
look into those as well so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day